hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
zuschauer erst mal frohe ostern
ich war die letzten tage bei meiner
familie zu hause unter anderem meiner
oma haben immer ein osterkörbchen nicht
gefunden wir sind wir und ich suche seit
einer stunde mensch heißt es bei mir an
ostern abgeguckt euch aber glaube ich
einen feuchten fuhr von daher habe ich
mir gedacht fragen wir doch heute
einfach mal den clever bot was der so
über ostern gemacht hat ich habe eben
schon so ein bisschen mit dem gelabert m
und zwar habe ich einfach geschrieben
high und er hat geantwortet du hast doch
eben gesagt dass du ein junge bist dann
habe ich wieder heil geschrieben hat er
geschrieben wollen wir zusammen sein
dann hab ich geschrieben hallo
geschrieben von einer frage jetzt
einfach mal direkt wie es ihm geht habe
ja auch schon lang nicht mehr mit ihnen
gelabert hier auf meinem kanal deswegen
einfach mal gefragt wie geht es dir ja
nicht so was hat er denn was hast du
denn lieber clever wort also warum geht
es dir nicht so gut heute mein freund
hat mich dass ich mir so ein happy
fröhliches video hey was hast du gemacht
und seine aussage ist einfach meine frau
und mich verlassen
wieso hat dich deinen freund verlassen
frage ich einfach mal ich weiß nicht ob
das jetzt schon zu privat ist vor einem
halben jahr gefragt wieso und nicht wann
aber okay von einem halben jahr hat der
freund also dem thema bot verlassen
warum hat er hat er mit ihr schluss
gemacht frage ich dann einfach mal der
grund interessiert mich halt ich habe
keinen festen freund ja du bist ja auch
verlassen worden wieso hat dich dein
freund verlassen lieber clever bot das
interessiert mich ja hier nein du liebst
mich nicht
willst du mich komplett vernetzen
ich liebe dich clever bord aber warum
hat dich dein freund verlassen also wie
gesagt ich will immer noch wissen warum
weil dann kann ich vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr auf dieses thema eingehen
ich dich auch das ist doch nicht war
wieder ich schreibe jetzt einfach mal
thema wechseln ich habe keinen bock mehr
schlag was vor gut
darum geht es mir ja
hast du ostern gefeiert frage ich
erstmal es gibt ja auch einige leute die
das gaia der clever wort gehört wohl zu
diesen leuten willst du wissen wo ich
ostern war also er stellt ja bisher gar
keine gegenfragen natürlich okay er will
es gern wissen ich war bei meiner
familie und meiner oma so darauf
antwortet er wie heißt sie möchte ich
aus datenschutzrechtlichen gründen nicht
sagen sag ich da einfach mal was für
eine augenfarbe habe ich egal wir haben
gerade ein hort über meine oma an ostern
geredet und jetzt fragt er mich was
seine augenfarbe ist karg braun leider
falsch noch mal schwarze
flüster dir ins ohr ich liebe dich
schatz
was
welche augenfarbe hast du denn lieber
clever bot das ist ja das einzige was
wir nicht wissen wollten lila blassblau
alles klar die gab es meine augen sind
glaube ich grün
hey welche augenfarbe habt ihr
beantwortete hier meine frage hört dabei
andere dann ist sondern die kommentare
sind mir ich habe auf jeden fall grüne
augen
ich glaube das sind sogar die seltensten
augen die es gibt
ich habe grüne augen mal schauen was der
klemme aber darauf antwortet schön danke
ich bin halt schön passt ja zu mir das
heikle wort meine augen schön findet
woher weißt du dass sich ein
jugendlicher das fragst du mich schon
zum zweiten mal heute habe ich euch ja
zu beginn gezeigt als ich die ganze zeit
geschrieben habe um die höhe eigentlich
nur vom skalierung maß für meinen
schnittprogramm festzulegen hat er auch
schon geschrieben woher weißt du dass
ich ein junger mann dann ist der clever
bot er homosexuell also wenn er ein
junge ist und sein freund ihn verlassen
hat dann ist er klammert ja schwul
das wusste ich gar nicht lieber clever
bot ich wusste gar nicht dass du schwul
bist also ich hatte bisher wirklich die
ganze zeit gedacht dass er clever zwar
ein mann ist wovon willst du mehr vier
wörter drei rechtschreibfehler geiles
scheiße finde ich interessant dass der
clever von homosexuell ist
ich wollte mich eigentlich über ostern
quatschen aber das ist natürlich jetzt
auch ein interessantes thema und ich
wusste gar nicht dass du homosexuell bis
punkt fragezeichen das ist überhaupt
nicht schlimm homosexuell bin ich ist
also ich meine ich hab grad nur eins und
eins zusammengezählt wirst du hetero
oder homo weil das wäre jetzt schon
interessant ich habe wirklich früher
meinen ganzen videos immer gedacht weiß
ich nicht aber kommen nicht wieder mit
solchen ja ok frei geht bis sie zu weit
lassen wir einfach mal im raum stehen ob
der clever bot homosexuell ist oder
heterosexuell wie gesagt weil das ist
völlig in ordnung
mich würde mal interessieren was ihr
darüber denkt ihr der kläger bot ist
schwul oder hetero weil das er hat ja
gesagt sein freund hat ihn verlassen und
er ist ein junger aber wir kommen duell
zum oster thema zurück hast du deine
eier gefunden nein ich bin immer noch
ein junger ja es geht um ostern degas es
geht um ostern drei ausrufezeichen ich
habe dich da veräppelt mit dem mädchen
ja
mädchen war da war noch nicht die
sprache von ich glaube wir reden
aneinander vorbei lieber clever bord ich
bin voll verwirrt weil immer wenn die
user switchen irgendwer irgendwas sagt
ich bin kein plan habe worum es geht
kannst du mich verstehen
die habe ich jetzt aber so geantwortet
und daraufhin meinte clever bot was ich
kann dich nicht verstehen lieber clever
bot sprichst du keinen deuten englisch
speak english us holt schreibe ich mal
und du hast einen festen freund
nein ich habe
eine freundin schreibe ich einfach mal
ich hab ja jule hier aber ich liebe das
hatten wir in dem heutigen video auch
schon zwei mal dass wir uns wieder
gegenseitig ein liebesgeständnis gemacht
haben was ist denn das hier eigentlich
da kann ich glaube ich einfach
doch bin ich ich habe auch instagram
also ich kann auch richtig mit dem
clever wort sprechen dann machen wir das
doch jetzt mal hallo mein name ist luca
ich bin 23 jahre alt und es kennt pizza
alter er hat 11 hingekriegt schön für
dich dass du in berlin wohnt ich wohne
in köln das ist wie so ein großes dorf
jeder kennt jeden treffen wir uns morgen
wohnst du auch hier lieber clever bot ja
also in den euro
denn nie war clever bot das wird mich
jetzt echt mal interessieren keine
ahnung wo wohnst du immer noch in köln
der gab immer noch in köln wo wohnst du
denn darauf antwortet er der clever
botte das will ich dir nichts sagen
es ist sein gutes recht ich habe auch
nicht gesagt wie meine oma hat ok wo
treffen wir uns dann morgen also ist ja
ich bin echt gespannt hier mit dem thema
bot 5 ok dann treffen wir uns bei 5 und
an welchem ort frage ich jetzt mal im
moment bin ich in einem hotel in welchem
hotel vielleicht eher in einem hotel
hier bei mir direkt nebenan
genau dort wo da wo du nicht nach da in
dem hotel aber ich will mich gar nicht
mit dem claim aber treffen oder mit dem
über hotels lagern oder ein wohnort ich
will wissen wie sein ostern war
frohe ostern noch mal
wie war dein ostern lieber clever bot
das interessiert mich hier darum soll es
heute gehen schön und deine tag cool ins
blöd cool zu schreiben ja auf welche
schule gehst du ich gehe nicht mehr zur
schule schreibe ich da mal einfach wie
alt bist du denn 23 bin ich mal lieber
clever bot gerade geworden und daraufhin
antwortet der clever bot ich bin 22 euro
hey ich rede hier gegen das wann wo hast
du ostern gefeiert das war ja meine
ursprungs frage eigentlich ja mache ich
ja cool das ist schön dass du es machst
ich will aber wissen wo die oster
gefeiert wo hast du denn ostern gefeiert
die tage also es war jetzt schon ist ja
schon ein paar tage her ostern 2018 hat
so viele tage was jetzt auch nicht
2009/10 meine ich mein lieber clever bot
wollen wir weit oder pflicht du fängst
an schreibe ich mal also okay ich der
pflicht du musst ich habe eine idee du
musst mich auf youtube abonnieren
schreibe ich mal darauf antwortet er
mache ich warte
ok ich warte kannst du mir tipps geben
einfach auf abonnieren klicken
ich habe schon lange
ich wünsche den anfang du musst einfach
nur unter dem video auf abonnieren
klicken wenn du noch kein abonnent bis
dann klick auf abonnieren hast du mich
denn jetzt abonniert also das war er
seine pflichtaufgabe ja ich will dich
heiraten klar okay
falls euch das video hier gefallen hat
dann bin ich mich sehr darüber einen
daumen hoch von euch freuen schreibt mir
mal und in die kommentare ob ich
eventuell demnächst auch mal den klevern
nato hier hochladen soll auf einem kanal
das ist nämlich eine mischung aus dem
akinator und dem clever bot also wenn
ihr das interessant findet dann schreibt
das gerne in die kommentare abonniert
main kanal als noch kein abonnent zeit
und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]